last year we committed to continuously
drive down costs for our customers in
alignment with Moore's law and since
then we announced three major price
reductions and we continue to lead the
industry in combining strong performance
with low cost as well as flexible
commitment free pricing options we
believe Google cloud platform delivers
better performance at lower cost than
other cloud providers you may wonder how
we're able to do this first we're
creating infrastructure that's tailored
to your workload not the other way
around
earlier this year we introduced Nearline
storage to dramatically reduce storage
costs by up to 70% for many classes of
content and data and more recently we
announced preemptable VMs a new class of
machine tailored specifically for
stateless applications such as Hadoop
processing and short-duration batch
workloads preemptable VMs can lower your
cost by as much as 70 percent compared
to standard VMs and they're perfect for
adding firepower to data processing
applications secondly we provide you
with the most appropriate billing plan
so you can save on costs automatically
you shouldn't have to spend hours or
days calculating rate plans and
different classes of machines we believe
that the cloud should do that for you
and for that reason we pioneered a
number of innovations in pricing
including per minute billing and
sustained use discounts options such as
these significantly lower your cost and
are provided to you automatically
third we don't force you to prepay to
get the discounts you deserve signing
long-term contracts reduces your
flexibility in our rapidly changing
environment as your business grows the
types of compute resources you need
change as well for example you may start
off on a standard VM but as you grow a
new class of machine may result in
dramatic savings reserved instance
pricing or other prepay schemes lock you
not only into the price but also into a
machine class and a location this works
only if you don't grow or if you have a
very good crystal ball so we give you
the flexibility change regions or
classes of machines to meet your
changing business needs with no penalty
and finally we're establishing firm
price performance benchmarks based on
Moore's Law so
as infrastructure becomes more efficient
and the price of the underlying hardware
continues to decline we are committed to
pass those savings on to you so taken
together we want to make sure that our
cloud platform provides the lowest total
cost of ownership and the highest
performance